on Saturday violent left-wing and Tifa
thugs assaulted police and right-wingers
in Boston as forty thousand protesters
surrounded 50 or so free speech
demonstrators will discuss where the
real threat to Liberty lives Plus
Antonio Okafor Amanda presto Giacomo and
Jacob arey joined the panel of
deplorable zhh to talk killer robots
anti-trump stunts on campus and
president Trump's disbanding of a global
warming advisory panel naga mega mega
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Doyle show
[Music]
so today is an all violence show we're
going to be talking about an Tifa we've
got Antonio Okafor sharpshooter
extraordinaire and so I figured in that
spirit I would show you just a little
clip of my weekend I was visiting a
friend of mine in Arizona and I think
this 18-second sums up the entire
weekend the Michael Noel's show here you
go
add three there we are well hopefully
the rest of the clips are able to play
maybe we'll send that out a little later
but anyway I got to shoot a lot of guns
this weekend Arizona is a great state
full of guns and freedom and America so
so now we spent a lot of time last week
talking about right-wing violence we
talked to a Charlottesville attendee we
analyzed the alt-right and what that
means with relation to conservatism and
to the right wing so today we have to
talk about antifa because over the
weekend there was this very small free
speech demonstration in Boston on
Saturday by all accounts that were not
neo-nazis there there were not white
supremacists there
one of the organizers is a man named
Shiva and not very many white
nationalist surname Shiva this was a
really small contained protest and then
the there were 40,000 by some counts
counter protesters they're typically
antifa which is short for anti-fascist
but which is ironic because they these
lefties take on fascistic tactics were
throwing urine at the police and rocks
and basically being criminal thugs and I
think this is the group that President
Trump was alluding to last week in his
much pilloried moral equivalence between
the Looney Tunes on the right and the
Looney Tunes on the left that the old
right is we kind these in half and he
linked that same group to those who
perpetrated
Charlie so well I don't know I can't
tell you I'm sure Senator McCain must
know what he's talking about but when
you say the alt-right define all right
to me you define it McCain defined them
as the same KCRG excuse me what about
the alt left they came charging at the
as you say the alt right do they have
any semblance of guilt now I see why
President Trump used this term the alt
left it's because he speaks in very
graphic or visual terms and he wants to
draw a comparison between these violent
people on the right the handful of
violent people that we saw in
Charlottesville and between these these
violent people that we see on the left
at every single event at Berkeley at
Milo Annapolis speech in a Coulter
speech I've been with Ben Shapiro at
CSULA when an Tifa people are beating
people up and not letting attendees go
into the auditorium so he wants to draw
this comparison and so he's using the
same word all right and all left but as
a as a concept it doesn't really make
sense because on the right and we say
there's the alt right we're saying it's
an alternative to mainstream
conservatism traditionally there are a
lot of groups that fall under the right
they're libertarians there's a religious
right they're the neoconservatives
there are the traditionalist
conservatives and the paleo cons and I
guess these 50 or 60 lunatic Nazis would
would identify themselves on the right
as well but on the left is especially
recently
it's basically monolithic so it there
used to be the progressives and the blue
dogs the more conservative Democrats the
more conservative lefties those blue
dogs have been run out of town so we're
just talking about different extremes of
progressivism and so I don't know that
it makes a lot of sense to call it an
alternative it just seems to give the
lefties who are willing to use violence
to suppress speech and out by saying oh
that's not us that's the alternative the
president Trump is acknowledging and no
less than P turbine are at the left-wing
commentator and the New York Times admit
this as much New York Times reporter at
Charlottesville said quote the hard left
seemed as heat filled as the OLT right
notice she said the hardly
not the old left not something different
but just the logical extreme of the left
seems as hate-filled as the old right I
saw a club wielding and Tifa beating
white nationalists being led out of the
park Peter Beinart clocks are right
broken clocks are right two times a day
said in a recent Atlantic piece on
left-wing violence quote and tifa's
violent tactics have elicited
substantial support from the mainstream
left in the Trump era the violent
leftist movement is growing like never
before from Middlebury to Berkeley to
Portland the use of violence to deny
Trump supporters their political rights
is on the rise especially among young
people and among other left-wing
organizations this is being heralded and
they're really being cheerleaders the
leftist magazine the nation argued to
call Trump fascist is to realize is
realize that it is not welcome batted or
contained by standard liberal appeals to
Reason which is why the radical left
offers quote practical and serious
responses in this political moment the
nation all but effectively endorsing
violence at these rallies they said that
the antifa attack on white nationalists
Richard Spencer was kinetic beauty slate
ran and approving article which would
play a little music as Richard Spencer
was being punched in the head and the
Obama speech writer John Favreau said
quote I don't care how many different
songs you set Richard Spencer being
punched to a laugh at everyone but now
nobody supports Nazis there are so few
of these people meanwhile the left owns
the culture CNN in an article they've
had to change the headline over the
weekend they ran an article with the
headline quote unmasking the leftist and
Tifa movement activists seek peace
through violence well hoon I guess that
excuses it doesn't they're just seeking
peace through violence absurd Orwellian
Newspeak but of course the the
mainstream Left is trying to cover for
these guys now ante fuh you know it
refers to anti-fascist it comes from
these European groups in the 20s and 30s
that were Reds that would fight fascists
in the street I came to it back then by
the way it organized around the
principle of triple oppression so racism
classism and sex
were the three organizing principles we
see this same concept today on the
mainstream left which is called
intersectionality the idea that
different groups are being oppressed for
different reasons and they all need to
unite together or to fight the man or to
fight the establishment I came to the
u.s. in the 90s with a bunch of kids who
liked punk music basically and they were
anarchists or communists or what have
you they wear masks because they're
cowards they don't want their names and
identities to be revealed and here is an
anti Fateh
explaining to CNN what they do mpesa is
any groups that's willing to stand up
against ashes by any means necessary by
any means necessary they say can mean
outing a white nationalist at their work
or to their neighbors or as we see
recently violent fires property damage
hand-to-hand combat at protests across
the country explain to me the reasoning
behind fighting you have to make it so
unpalatable to be doing white
supremacist organizing that they no
longer want to do that and historically
that's what's worked you have to put
your body in the way and you have to
make it speak in the language that they
understand and sometimes that is
violence what about people who will say
that it is their right to free speech
even if it's hate speech but we do think
the communities have the right to step
in and say no this is not acceptable in
our communities we will not stand for
this at least they're honest at least
these guys are honest because that is
the point you know free speech exists
the First Amendment exists not to
protect popular speech you wouldn't need
an amendment you wouldn't need a right
to protect popular speech it exists to
protect unpopular speech and even
odious hateful speech these guys say
absolutely not and that you know this is
what the mainstream Left wants to do now
these guys say we're only targeting
Nazis we're only targeting white
supremacists I think anybody who voted
for Mitt Romney they would probably
consider a white supremacist they they
define these terms very broadly and
they're not just attacking Richard
Spencer they're attacking and ben
shapiro they're attacking milo innopolis
they're attacking Ann Coulter they're
attacking people who give speeches at
colleges there
attacking social scientists like charles
murray who was on the losing end of
violence from these people when he gave
a speech you know when they're not being
violent they're trying to suppress
speech through the standard mechanisms
of government so the left has been
campaigning for years to overturn the
Citizens United decision because it
grants too much political speech to
people who might oppose them I mean that
decision actually centered around a
movie that was critical of Hillary
Clinton
we see this in speech codes at Google
last week at Mozilla the CEO of Mozilla
being kicked out for holding a
politically correct incorrect point of
view we see it at professors at
universities being fired simply for
defending free speech this happened at
my own dear old Yale so whereas these
Looney Tunes on the right or expressing
a lot of ideas that are totally
antithetical to mainstream conservatism
on the left we're seeing the logical
extremes of this thought here's yeah
here's another clip clip 7 look at self
giving mommy why people give your mom
how you're in property related you know
rapper rate slap and indigent people
right now hey hey hey judge your time
it's your money and your life is now
devoted to social change it really is
are some people some penis are killing
no one help your white house let die Oh
mine is a buck oh yeah the White House
July we would say this is this is a
total crazy extreme we don't hear
anybody defending these people but we do
here is a perfectly well dressed
articulate Dartmouth College professor
defending the antifa movement you seem
to be a very small minority here who is
defending the idea of violence
considering that somebody died in
Charlottesville
why do you defend confronting in a
violent one well first we can test the
notion that I'm that small of a minority
I think that a lot of people recognize
that when pushed self
defend is a legitimate response to white
supremacist and neo-nazi violence and
you know we've tried ignoring neo-nazis
in the past we've seen how that turned
out in the 20s and 30s a nun lesson of
history is you need to take it with the
utmost seriousness before it's too late
we've seen the millions of deaths that
have come from not taking it seriously
enough and we can see that really the
way that white supremacy grows the way
that neo Nazism grows is by becoming
legitimate becoming established becoming
everyday family friendly wear khakis
instead of hoods and the way to stop
that is what people did in Boston what
people did in Charlottesville pull the
emergency brake and say you can't make
this normal Richard the key word here is
violence listen to how insidious this is
how he's redefining violence
now antifa didn't organize in response
to Charlottesville they've been around a
lot longer than Charlottesville but
they're not reacting to physical
violence they're reacting to a
redefinition of speech as violence so
they're saying not not only does speech
call people to violence or not only does
speech create an environment that is
more conducive to violence what they're
saying is that speech is literally
violent and we see this at all levels on
universities all the way up through a
corporate American through the
government there are such things as
microaggressions the reason they define
speech this way is because by calling an
aggression it justifies an aggressive
and violent response we saw this even
with Richard Spencer I am no fan of
Richard Spencer I think he what he does
is destructive to the right and to the
country but here's what they did to him
when he was just speaking to a cameraman
here there weren't enough India moving
its cafes become kind of it
total coward comes up with his hood on
with a with a mask over his face and
sucker punches this guy while he's
talking and giving an interview and it's
so easy to say well I can't shed too
many tears for some Nazi getting punched
in the head but these guys malign
everybody on the right as Nazis hears
them talking to a guy who has defended
our country is a military veteran listen
to how they speak to our biggest
military veteran defended our country in
Afghanistan is so that criminal Lefty
hippie looking thugs could call him a
Nazi and shout him down well he's
defending free speech absolutely
unbelievable props to the editing team
for getting everything amazing I mean I
don't know how they got all of this
obscenities out of that because the way
these people speak is every third word
is the f-word I think it's the only word
they know because to write well is to
think clearly and they can do neither
with that we have to bring on our panel
we're very lucky today we have Antonio
Okafor Amanda presto Giacomo and
Jakob very even Jacob Ari Antonio
President Trump was pilloried for
appearing to draw an equivalence between
these two groups the Nazis and neo-nazis
white nationalists and an tyfa is that
defensible or they are they two sides of
the same coin or is one side worse
yeah well I think personally I do think
that they are on the same playing field
why and actually I think NC was worse in
the fact that would Jesus didn't miss
sources like CNN are saying that it's
okay you know peace through violence I
mean who who says that CNN apparently al
Jazeera apparently so I think it's
really important to become a thing we're
just like a Dartmouth professor very
saying it's khakis instead of hoodies
well same thing on Antipa side where
they basically are legitimizing this in
making it a normal site for someone to
to harass and harm someone because they
think they're a racist or sexist and
misogynist I mean it's getting really
bad so the fact of the matter is I
should be considered a racist sexist
misogynist you all died on separate
that's ever with you and I see in
general somebody like you of course
absolutely so yeah I think it is low
German I don't think what President
Trump said was far off I think people
are just blowing out of proportion
people were hurt on both sides if people
want to see violence look at UC Berkeley
what happened there I mean and those
weren't even white supremacists there
who are hurt from Antipa so um yeah
earthly we saw people setting things on
fire breaking windows hurling water
bottles full of urine throwing rocks
macing people and we say and and you're
right
nobody I don't know anybody who is
defending these Nazis in Charlottesville
or these white supremacists but we have
every single person on the left of any
antifa we have the major institutions
CNN the mainstream news outlets it
unbelievable Jacob the media finally are
beginning to cover an Tifa they've been
silent about them the whole time they've
been wreaking havoc on political rallies
is it because of President Trump is it
because he called out the alt left in
that speech or is it 4d chess on the
part of the President or would they have
been covering this anyway no I think
because you saw whenever they were
assaulting speakers at colleges college
campuses at Berkeley and so on radio
silence from the main store
Media I think it I can't hear Jacob it
is because of a trump calling out the
alt left specifically I think that they
that the mainstream media would not have
covered this at all had Trump said
nothing is even Chris Cuomo he sent out
that tweet comparing and sefa to the the
veterans who stormed Normandy
what was he thinking why would you even
suggest that there is absolutely no
comparison whatsoever
absolutely they I do not think the
veterans do storm Normandy I don't think
the men who took the cliffs
looked like that sorry letting look
alike yeah I notice our veterans they
don't wear masks they proudly show who
they are these an Chief Accountant
handkerchiefs to cover up their faces
absolutely now Amanda we all agree we've
got to oppose an Tifa can we oppose
these guys these criminals without
making common cause with Nazis is there
any way to do it without aligning
ourselves with these other people that
we also want to have nothing to do with
yeah that's such a ridiculous line from
the left they're saying that if you call
it an Tifa you're condoning neo-nazis
which is absurd you know the media and
Democrats are basically off the hook
when it comes to an Tisa which is really
disturbing they're not being asked to
condemn them just like every Republican
anyone you know even semi associated
with the right is being asked to condemn
them every five seconds over and over
and over repeatedly that giant Aoife is
such a big threat because nobody's being
asked to condemn them and they're
they're kind of condoning this behavior
like CNN pieces which is another major
outlets where they're basically
condoning the violence and like you said
before this has been happening for a
long time been happening on college
campuses and they said nothing until
President Trump called them by name I
think he should have called them my name
is s business first statement but still
because he's called them by name finally
the media are being forced to cover them
and the coverage is honestly really weak
why don't we tell CNN to disavow you
know that's always a always in politics
if you're defending you're losing you
have to always be on offense and
conservatives Republicans all the time
have to disk
alleys miniature vanishingly small
minorities of groups who say hateful
things that they've never met before why
doesn't why does in the New York Times
have to disavow antiva or or a
democratic politician just one can they
disavow them honestly I haven't seen
hardly anyone disavow this on the left
but every republican has come out
against these twenty by the way that
dozen I own Otzi's they had bet that was
a national rally in Charlottesville they
had 200-300 apparent at all there's no
certainly ten of these guys in people
get every college campus they're
everywhere and yet you know we can just
condone that and not you know them it's
ridiculous but the left love that they
they just find one or two little Nazis
one incident and all of a sudden all of
the right is associated with them
meanwhile these these awful events at
colleges and elsewhere have been going
on for two years and the media
absolutely mum but that's what they are
that darn mainstream media okay we have
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
now what we would love for you to do is
come on over to the Daily wire calm and
then you can watch the rest of this
excellent panel of deplorable there it's
only ten dollars a month
one hundred dollars a year you get me
you get the Andrew Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show better than all of
that you get the leftist here's tumblr
this leftist you're some where is the
greatest tumblr I've ever owned because
just regular old tumblers a regular old
mugs they don't keep my leftist tears
chilled and delicious but this this will
keep your leftist tears hot or cold
always salty so go over right now daily
wire calm we'll be right back
oK we've got to get into other news but
still speaking of violence inventor Elon
Musk is leading a group of 116
specialists from 26 countries to call
for a global ban on killer robots
so Amanda the son has disappeared from
the sky Nazis and communists are
fighting in the streets killer robots
are on the horizon is the end knife yeah
there's so much hysteria um I don't know
it's on about these killer robots and
that's kind of a thing I don't think
anybody knows it's not about this it's
kind of like reminiscent of global
warming a little bit like the hysteria
around it so then they can kind of do
whatever they want so basically I just
hate everything about this story I hate
technology I hate that there's things we
don't really know about and we're just
creating things about thinking of
repercussions
then I also hate that things like lobe
list agenda - you know like some big
global network to stop us to ban these
things what does that mean what are the
implications of that are we going to
have eventually military action if
somebody breaks this ban I mean what
there's a lot going into this and people
don't know a lot about it so it it's
just a really I don't know I don't like
anything out the baha humbug the Amanda
Prestidge Akamai tech Jessica this you
know this reminds me of nuclear
proliferation we've had people
predicting since the 40s that it's
inevitable that every country is going
to get a nuke you can't keep a lid on
this technology seems like we're trying
to do the same thing and by the way
we've done a pretty good job with
nuclear non-proliferation given how long
it's been since the technology was
invented are these killer robots
inevitable or can we stop the technology
before the Terminator begins well the
irony is a lot of these tech mogul zhh
they would be the guys who would
actually create these killer robots so
III think that every every year like at
least once or twice a year one of these
tech CEOs comes out and they say it I
honestly think it's a distraction they
they just come out when when
everything's high-pressure when when the
left is going crazy or whatever they
come because most of the
on the left they come out and they
complain about a robot apocalypse and
all of a sudden the headlines are Elon
Musk warns of robot apocalypse so you
think it's a distraction I totally think
it's a distraction Wow
that I love the conspiracies theory
could be though I wouldn't put it past
them Antonia you are the weapons expert
on the panel today now it is it safer
for us to try to get rid of these
weapons or have a global ban or would it
be safer to have responsible actors all
have them so that we don't use them
against each other in a phrase should we
say more killer robots less crime are
you trying to get me to say that
weapon-free zones are good things the
gun activists will never be okay with
that
you know what it's a reality of it and I
mean the same thing like reality that
vendors are going to keep their guns
Americans are gonna take your gun
there's gotta be a weapon thing done so
at least be on the right side of it and
make sure that the ones who shouldn't
see having weapons don't so I think it
kind of goes with everything I kind of
think also it's funny you know me being
agonised activist been Tifa bringing it
back of course that keeping people are
the people who probably would be against
me having a firearm or any weapon of any
kind but it's okay for them or be able
to do it because peace through violence
is okay
as long as it's out there and they're
going to defend you and what you don't
need to be able to defend yourself
they've got you covered just let them
handle it what could possibly go wrong
absolutely that was exactly what there
were a New York Times piece on that and
that is what almost every person a bit
near kind of audience would say was like
you don't even need a gun why do you use
in and then they're like you know what
antifa is great and keep it laundry but
you really don't need a gun on college
campuses and pipa is there but you
really have yeah not a cognitive
dissonance at all absolutely we will
empower you by allowing you to empower
us I don't know how they can resolve
that but speaking of college campuses a
group of Liberty University alumni are
symbolically giving back their diplomas
because they're upset that the
university president Jerry Falwell Jr
supports president Trump now Antonia you
can't actually give back a degree so in
these kids apply for jobs they'll still
have their BA and they'll have
everything is there any substance to
this grandstanding is there anything at
all that they're doing or is it just
like on Facebook they're just virtue
signaling
oh well look when I heard that I first
of all I was like who are these Liberty
University graduates do they know they
went to Liberty University and I mean
sighs to me his company his all makes an
announcement I mean for a reason
supposed to say that it's kind of like
what Baylor University when you know
atheists go to Baylor and I see them and
I'm just like you really can't complain
I mean they were the breakers what a
bigot yeah if you hate that too you know
Baptists I don't think you should go
online there thanks Liberty if you hate
anything on the conservative side on the
right side and you think your president
your school president is not going to be
okay with the president who's a
Republican I mean the same thing when
you said it's my goal yes what a great
gesture that you gave back your diploma
but then when you go and like interview
for energy and people Boston yeah tell
them that you're okay with that
but then you still have your BA on the
side doesn't pay if you know you decide
that when you log into monster.com you
type in antiques or pumps and I hope
they're hiring that's like I hear
Michael is it that's a tough job market
you know Amanda I'm really opera on
Antonia's point why did these kids go to
Liberty why did they apply how did they
get in this is supposed to be all
Christian all conservative is there just
now no hope for college at all or is
there something in the college
experience right now that just forces
people into becoming leftist drones yeah
I think I think it's a letter I mean
this is this is so funny I mean they're
they're upset that colleges are too
conservative like Turkish it's just a
crazy thought just generally speaking
that you know the problem of college is
a too conservative I know Liberty
University's obviously Christian and
conservative so they knew that going in
but it's just it's just all silly it's
just peak virtue signaling they're just
they're handing back a piece of paper
that's literally what they're doing
they're not hating master degree they're
not doing anything this is like the
equivalent of you know those 10 people
have CNN coverage so big that spelled
out resistance on the beach with sticks
like this doesn't do any
that I don't I don't understand what
this does I mean well and there are no
stakes to it there it's one thing to
give back something of value to lose
something of value for your beliefs
these guys they're not out there
protesting like the civil rights
movement or other civil rights movements
with their their faces wide in the open
repercussions readily available being
arrested for civil disobedience these
guys are wearing masks they're covering
their faces they're running away wire
why are they all such cowards
look my I just weren't hit as children
honestly I did a beating when they were
younger
these kids never got that you can tell
just how they act that's Lucky's talk
school of parenting where you get
smacked with the wooden spoon yeah yeah
I thought that's how I was raised and I
hear him talk I feel like we were raised
in the same household um no I mean it's
they're just spoiled little brat who
don't have anything on the line I mean
like I said they cover their face they
send back a piece of paper that has
nothing connected to their actual degree
I mean it's just all birth to signaling
and by the way in Boston there were no
being Nazis so they were fightin or they
fight like they're fighting a phantom
they were fighting against free speech
that's right well they're they're
fighting this phantom that they want to
be able to paint over all of the right
but really as you said a national
protest in Charlottesville organized for
months attracts what a couple hundred of
these idiots Jacob that what that was
clearly the incident obviously a lot of
these responses have come out of
president Trump's response to
Charlottesville these had to dissolve a
couple of his advisory panels and it
what is it about that response to
Charlottesville that has elicited what
is without a doubt the strongest
reaction of his presidency I honestly
think it was his tone I mean he came out
we're going to grab the bull by the
horns right and I honestly think the
mainstream media doesn't know what to do
about this I mean they're already
against and they think of him as a
traitor of the left and so they're
already out against him and they and
they are just going crazy that he is
just saying look this is how it is this
is what
I believe whether he is correct or not
that's that doesn't matter they are
going to just they're just going to keep
slamming him and they're just going to
keep reacting and they're going to it's
just putting pressure on these advisory
boards so they saw an opening it with
with that you know scare is a serious
word in the language not see there's not
opening and they pounced on it it's
always the Boogie and they always find
some sort of boogeyman and this time
it's it's not these and you know it's
not entirely a boogeyman there were a
couple hundred people down there one of
them did kill a woman and hit some other
well I mean in the context of how the
mainstream media is reporting of course
absolutely well we need some good news
it's all been killer robots and auntie
fun Nazis you know we need some good
news and we got it president Trump has
disbanded a federal global warming
advisory report now Amanda is this
evidence that President Trump might stay
the course even as Steve Bannon leaves
the White House a lot of the Republicans
who were there in the beginning have
left the White House is this hopefully a
sign of hope for the future yeah I think
it's a great sign I mean Trump is
governed pretty conservatively I mean I
know he says things as a media pounced
on but he's not I mean he's pretty
mainstream conservative and then he'll
take thing to stuff even further right
than most presidents like this and
disband this dumb Climate Advisory Board
this would implement some really harmful
really harmful agenda policy so yeah I
think it's a great stuff and I love this
kind of stuff from Trump this will keep
me hunting Trump even if the media gopis
teracle over things he says and then one
other point about what Jacob was saying
last time how the media just overreacted
to president Trump's statement if you
looked at if you look at Mitt Romney
what he said about antifa
he basically says that they were fine
like this is a fine group and that just
again shows that the media is not
accustomed to Republican actually
speaking out and speaking truth and
saying things that are unpopular but
true that's right they love Republicans
who lose their always in retrospect are
always very though they were great men
those Republicans who in no way
threatened my political agenda now
that is the worry about this political
agenda is that President Trump is going
to make some arnold schwarzenegger pivot
to the left that's basically what Steve
Bannon is saying is going to happen now
Jacob or rather in Tony I like to hear
from you first on this what do you think
is he about to pivot to the left is or
is Steve Bannon just upset that he left
the White House
oh yeah I don't see on us though I've
been I was a conservative I just don't
think I mean everybody who's on the
who's not concerned he's not going true
because they're really especially since
therefore mostly populist they already
had a lot of authoritarian and them so I
kind of I could disagree anyways over at
a lot of his policies and what he didn't
so I probably think he's or you going so
up anyway sometimes it was always that
happen you thought it I think there was
basically built-in dress campaign yeah
it's already happening that's the type
of thing but I mean like again the
Conservatives in it when the white house
populace is so we get the morsels that
crumb
you know the crumbs that we can get and
say well it isn't Hillary we get a
little deregulation at least we don't
get new regulation take what we can get
but don't have don't put our faith in
princes Jacob why would president Trump
choose to do this now there's all this
craziness going on did President Trump
disband this panel this advisory board
because of the news cycle because the
news cycle has been so against him or is
he just holding course and doing it to
poke a finger in the media's eye I could
see either one of those being true I
actually think it's a little bit of both
a president Trump when he backed out of
the Paris climate Accord he destroyed
their religion science ISM and
environmentalism has replaced faith for
the left and I honestly think that he
was planning to do this and he thought
hey this is a perfect time I'm getting
all this bad publicity because of my my
speech with what happened with
Charlottesville so I'm going to do this
right now and it will it'll change the
headlines away and it will just be able
to go back because really climate change
there it's indefensible
I mean there's some points that are
accurate about it or what area I think
it is indefensible that Al Gore would
choose to heat up this earth it's really
really reckless of him to do that yes
with all that al Jazeera money so I do
see that it's not that President Trump
is trying to change the headline to get
a decent headline he's just trying to
get the media mad about something else
and that's what he's good at
he they he played it's like the Pied
Piper he plays it and they follow right
along for DHS endorsed by jakub area
okay panel it's been very nice to have
you
Antonio Kapoor Amanda presto Giacomo and
Jacob arey now it is time I have to put
on my smart glasses because it's time
for the final thought president Trump's
drawing of moral equivalence between
neo-nazis and antiva thugs seemed
tone-deaf at the time because it
miscalculated the enormity of the
offenses and teef amazed people hurled
rocks at them beat protesters sure but a
neo-nazi killed a woman with his car of
course both sides are odious yet while
Republicans and conservatives at all
levels from the grassroots to the White
House swiftly condemned the criminals
and kook's on their side Democrats have
kept a virtually mum on antifa
because while neo Nazism and white
nationalism remain a fringe element on
the right a vanishingly small
alternative to everybody else leftist
violence to suppress speech is
widespread and even encouraged by
cheerleaders not on some fringe out left
but right square in the mainstream
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow we'll do it
all again
[Music]